♪ You've been with me all along ♪
♪ All along ♪
♪ Always on my side, you've never gone ♪
♪ You've been weak all along ♪
- I only have 300 subscribers right now.
(gentle music)
♪ And you've been holding on, holding on ♪
- And thank my subscribers
so far, all 433 of you.
To most people that might
not seem like a lot,
but to me, that sounds like a huge number.
433 people have subscribed to my channel.
(upbeat music)
♪ Laugh or cry ♪
♪ Anywhere I stood, you were standing by ♪
♪ With me when I'm fine ♪
- [Interviewer] My question for you is,
if God could do one
miracle in your life today,
what would it be?
- So basically just like,
a wish that I think is unreal?
- [Interviewer] Biggest
miracle you could think of.
- To get me a million
subscribers on YouTube.
- [Interviewer] A million
subscribers on YouTube?
- Yep.
- Very cool.
♪ You've been with me all along ♪
♪ All along ♪
♪ Always on my side, you've never gone ♪
♪ You've been with me all along ♪
♪ And you've been holding on ♪
(lively music)
- Let's get started.
(coins rattling)
(geese honking)
Here, you got it, you got it.
So I'm about to pick up
my best friend Allison.
I don't usually need that much
help when I film episodes,
but when I do, Allison is
always willing to help me.
Basically, I have this really big gift
that I'm pretending to give to a stranger.
It's inside of an envelope,
and there is a letter
that goes along with it.
So I'm gonna tell her like,
"Hey Allison, can you read the letter
"and tell me if its good?
"Do you think a stranger will like it?"
And she's gonna read it,
and the more she reads,
the more she'll realize
that the gift is actually for her.
I'm gonna write the letter
while I wait for her.
So, yeah.
'Kay, go stand in the shot.
Here, put the flowers here though.
Take a step to the left,
your right, I mean.
Okay, so I am gonna give you
the gift that I'm gonna give the stranger.
- Okay.
Really, what if I'm just like, why don't,
like, can I be the stranger?
(Thoraya laughs)
You're kinda thankful for me, I thought.
So I have to read the note?
- [Thoraya] Yeah, tell me if it's good.
- You're really gonna give this away?
Aw.
Stop, no, oh my God!
Thoraya, stop. (laughs)
- [Thoraya] Yay, got you.
Allison, it's not even that big of a deal.
(both laughing)
Whoo!
- But I'm not a stranger. (chuckles)
Aw.
- [Thoraya] What were you
thinking when you saw the wallet?
- Okay, so we were walking and I was like,
"Oh wow, there's a wallet on the floor."
And we were just talking
about getting ice cream,
and I was like, "There's
money in the wallet!"
(woman laughs)
And I knew
'cause it was suspiciously like this.
(Thoraya chuckles)
And I was like,
"No one leaves their
wallet out like that."
And , but this is very
cool, thank you. (laughs)
- [Thoraya] Cool. (laughs)
- So cute.
- Wait up, let me show them what's in it.
#KindPranks.
Yes, you can really keep this! (chuckles)
A Starbucks gift card.
And 50,
20, five, $77.
Okay, okay, here we go.
(kids chattering)
- Look.
(kids laughing)
I found it on the ground.
- Yes, let's share it for Legoland.
- Hi, (laughs) I love you.
You make really cute videos.
- [Thoraya] Thank you, I appreciate it.
Oh, look at that guy. (chuckles)
Okay, his reaction was good,
his reaction was so good.
- (laughing) What are
you guys doing this for?
- This is my YouTube channel.
You're the best reaction so far.
- [Woman] You're the only reaction.
- (laughs) You're the only reaction.
Whoo, okay.
Okay guys so, Lana's standing outside.
She thinks that I'm in here
buying AirPods for a stranger,
but I'm actually buying it for her.
And I just want to thank her
for helping me today, so.
(crowd murmuring)
Okay, let's go.
- [Lana] Here she comes.
- [Thoraya] Lana, read this.
Tell me if it's good for the stranger.
- Hey stranger, what?
(Thoraya laughing)
I'm gonna cry.
- [Thoraya] Whoo, are you
really crying? (laughs)
Got ya, you had no idea, I was so nervous.
I made Lana cry.
- All right.
- Why was I so nervous?
- Why would you do that?
Follow my TikTok,
(Thoraya laughs)
same with my Instagram.
- I woke up today, and
just felt like being kind.
Should we just hand it to her?
Excuse me, we're just going around,
and giving away boxes of Oreos.
Could we give you one?
- [Woman] I don't need one today.
- Okay, all right, thanks
anyway. (chuckling)
Kindness rejected. (laughs)
- [Man] Hi, welcome to
Starbucks, how can I help you?
- Hello, can I get,
and then also I would like to
pay for the person behind me.
Hi, can I--
- Welcome back.
I saw that.
(Thoraya laughs)
- I guess I'll get a
brownie this time, and then,
same thing, I'll pay for the
person behind me as well.
- Hello, again.
- Hi. (chuckles)
- I would also like to pay
for the person behind me.
I want to see their reaction.
Oh, yay! (laughs)
- You've had enough time
to even finish a drink?
(Thoraya chuckles)
- [Lana] I don't know, he was--
(Thoraya laughs)
- Pay for the person behind me.
- [Man] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
I actually don't have a question,
I just wanted to give you guys
these Starbucks gift cards.
- Aw.
- Thank you.
- [Thoraya] You were
scared about the question?
- Yeah.
- [Thoraya] Okay, so I actually
don't have a question today.
I just wanted to give you guys
these Starbucks gift cards.
- Oh my god, thank you.
- (gasps) What?
- Oh my God, that's awesome.
You made my day, thank you.
- Literally.
- [Thoraya] Gift card.
- Have a great day, God bless you.
- Aw, thanks, aw. (laughs)
- [Thoraya] That's it.
- Not bad at all.
(Thoraya laughs)
That just made my day.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
That's it.
- Thank you.
- [Thoraya] Yeah, you get one.
I just wanted to give you
this Starbucks gift card.
Bye.
- Thank you,
I was having a bad day too.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, you're welcome.
- Have a nice day.
- Do you want one too?
(Thoraya chuckles)
- Sure.
- Oh my God, really?
Is that it?
- Yeah, that's it.
- Hey, thank you.
- [Thoraya] Could I
ask you a question too?
- What's up?
- [Thoraya] I just wanted to
give you a Starbucks gift card.
- I'm gonna pay it forward,
and pass it on to somebody else.
Happy Holidays, and I appreciate it.
- [Thoraya] Thank you
man, have a good one.
- You're awesome.
- [Thoraya] So actually,
I don't have a question,
I just wanted to give you guys
these Starbucks gift cards.
- Oh, wow.
- Wow.
I'm gonna cry.
- What? (laughs)
- [Thoraya] You're welcome,
thanks for stopping.
I do this project where I go out
and I ask strangers a question every week.
And I just want to thank
people who are willing to stop
all the time.
- Oh.
- So you just wanna give me a gift card?
- Yeah.
- All right.
- [Thoraya] For Starbucks. (chuckles)
- Cool, thank you.
- [Thoraya] Have a good one.
I'm almost out of time,
and I'm nowhere near 1,000,000 kind acts.
I know there's something I could do,
I just don't know what it is yet.
Hi, I'm interested in getting
a billboard in San Diego.
Did I call the right number?
- [Man] Yeah, definitely.
- I do have a budget of,
and I want it to be in the San Diego area.
- [Man] I'm gonna look at
the options we've got available right now,
and I'll give you a call back shortly.
- Okay, perfect, thank you so much.
Whew.
Hello.
- [Man] You've got a couple options,
but one really stuck out to
me as a pretty good deal.
It's on Clairemont Mesa
Boulevard in San Diego.
- Do you know how many people
would be seeing it, possibly?
- [Man] Yeah, for a week,
we expect about 997,970
people to drive by it,
and see the billboard.
(upbeat music)
♪ I can feel it ♪
♪ There's something in the water ♪
♪ Anything is possible ♪
♪ Come on and move like
the power of the river ♪
♪ Anything is possible ♪
♪ Oh, oh, whoa, oh, oh, whoa ♪